you've seen some some uh hacker moves in the
90s quite often included a certain scene where
you'd have a lovely super villain style map of
the world and somebody would say something like
oh my goodness the police are intercepting the
call and you see a lovely map and you see a little
line working its way across the map what i would
try and do is use some uh standard unix tools
traceroute which uh a lot of people who've done
system administration be very very familiar with
i thought i'd hack up a bit of python and see what
we can see see if we can get something that looks
a little bit like that classic hacker movie scene
we're going to auckland university in new zealand
and now we can get up our result and we can
see it's hopping from the uk oh to america
over to the west coast america and
then a massive transoceanic cable
all the way into the ocean
winding up in new zealand
i'd like to talk about the traceroute command
and uh is it as it sounds traces a route yeah
but actually there's quite a quite beautiful
little hack here it's quite a nice um nice
way that it's working so i'd like to
explain that show a few examples and
sure you can be a little bit of a tourist
using traceroute you can learn a bit
about how the network is working this is the
network the internet right the internet of
course yes it works for the whole internet
with some caveats which i'll explain so
in theory we can find the route from anywhere that
we've got access to a computer to anywhere else
in theory let me draw a few routers or routers
if you're an american and let's imagine i'm
sitting here this is my laptop some server
up here and there's some kind of network
connecting all of these things and we
want to be able to answer the question
which way is the traffic really going before we
learn about traceroute there's another command
we need to think about and that's ping pings a
lovely little utility that you use just to test
if something's alive if a bit of network hardware
is connected to the network written in 1983
it sends out an internet control message and the
message is icmp echo request it asks a computer
or a router to send back a message
saying i'm live i'm working okay
so if we want to check if a particular computer
is working we send out that ping icmp echo request
and if it is working that computer sends
back icmp echo reply and the ping command
gets that back and you know that
you've got a connection to our computer
now what we want to know now not just that this
machine here is working and responding to pings
but we also want to know the route now this wasn't
actually designed into the internet this ability
it was hacked in later something we
need to know about here is what's called
time to live every internet protocol packet when
it's created is set up with this flag time to live
it's as if they've all got a doomsday
clock on them um we've got a little counter
every time the packet goes through a router
that time to live counter decrements by one so
and there's a very good reason for that because
if your network is misconfigured you can get what
we call a routing loop so imagine somehow we'd
messed up our configuration and traffic that was
meant to go to this red router here ends up
going around in a circle and that can happen
now once that starts to happen the
traffic's just going to carry on
going around in that loop you've got big problem
because that's going to fill up your network so
they made this little design choice to have
the time to live counter and when that reaches
zero they just go this packet's stuck it's
expired we're going to throw it away and this
allows a really neat trick so this was created
by van jacobson one of the great creators of
the internet he's one of the men who made the
internet work and helped in the fundamental
design of transmission control protocol but
also this is of just a brilliant contribution
because he realized that this time to live counter
could be exploited normally you'd set it very high
so that the only reason it would expire is if your
packet was stuck in one of these routing loops
but if you cheat a bit if you set that
route that time to live very very low
you can set it to one so my packet sets off from
here gets here the time to live was one and the
packet is expired the router then must send back
a ttl expired message which you can get back to
your computer and now you've got a message from
this first hop go again set the time to lift to
two it decrements to one decrements again and now
you're going to get ttl expired from this route
here you're going to find out what your second hop
is time to lift three get a message from this one
time to live four you get a message from this one
and by sending subsequent packets with different
time to lives you can find out every hob on your
journey very neat that's cool it's very cool
there's a little catch because actually you're not
really getting a root these are different packets
so if you play with this command enough sometimes
you'll see that in between this packet being sent
and this packet being sent maybe the roots have
changed sometimes changed so sometimes you get
something where the second hop is here but
then the third hop is also here because the
route originally was like that and the route was
switched to be like that and the route was changed
halfway through your probe but it's it's a lovely
little hack that can tell you the way packets find
the way through a network what i thought i'd try
and do is get a little bit of python together to
sort of try and capture that that thing of uh
the packets leaping across the map of the world
so let's first let's just have a look at a basic
ping command which i'm sure most of you see before
so i'm going to use universe there's a very good
reason i'm using universities we don't always have
a huge budget so we we tend to have our web
server being one machine somewhere in iraq um
other companies big companies like
google they're doing something a little
more sophisticated so if i ping my university
queen mary university we're gonna get ping back
but we can also trace through to it
so this is a traceroute going from my flat in
south london well from my isp down to queen mary
university and we can see in the middle here it's
going through janna the giant academic network
a little thing that's happened here it's going to
the stars that means some network administrator in
the intervening path is blocking our packets now
there's a number of reasons that administrators
decide i don't want these ping packets i
don't want these tracery packets on my network
there used to be an attack called a smurf attack
where people used ping to to cause all kinds of
network disruption but also you might decide
you know what you don't want external people
to know what your interior network wiring looks
like so we when we get to these stars that means
the administrator there has taken the decision
to block my internet control message protocol
my uh requests to see inside their network
we'll try a nice long tray suit and we
think sydney university is a good long way
away so we might see something interesting
each of these lines is one hop of the journey but
there's actually each hop of the journey we've got
three packets so we get three estimates of the
round trip time so here we can see it's jumped
from 52 milliseconds response to 250 milliseconds
response so we can infer that between hot 11 and
hop 15 here it's probably gone across an ocean and
maybe here between hop where it's 250 at hops 17
and here probably it's gone across another
ocean there so we're getting eventually
360. well i discovered something quite nice
here if i actually go for the web server so i
go to the www.sydney.edu.edu we'll see a little
bit of a different story it stops a lot earlier
it stops here at this akamai technologies
i don't know if you know the company akamai
is that like a local copy or something yes exactly
that yeah brilliant yeah that's exactly what it is
a lot of people don't know about them but these
companies like akamai and limelight content
cdn content distribution content delivery networks
most of the traffic you get off the internet if
you're going to youtube netflix whatever you
aren't going to a single server somewhere in
america you're going to the local copy they've
mirrored and sydney university has quite sensibly
decided you know what we're in australia we're
a long way from a lot of people are trying to
access our website we'll pay these people a
bit of money and they'll they'll put a copy
closer so that's quite an interesting thing we can
see but the other thing i thought i'd do is to um
turn this into that scene we sometimes see in the
hacker movies or a little bit so let's look over
here at some point we can do what we call ipg
geolocation doesn't always work what we try and
do is take an ip address and work out where it is
in the world so here's a little bit of python code
that takes a string that's an internet protocol
address i'm using version 4 because i'm
old-fashioned and i'm kind of used to that but
this is taking that string sending out to this
particular company getting back a response and
we can pass out of that response that company
gives us a latitude and a longitude now there's
no mechanism in the internet that allows that
all they've done is they've got a database
and they're saying who owns that ip address
so it's not always perfectly accurate you
get some funny things coming up like if the
only thing they know is that that company is in
america it will return the latitude and longitude
the center yeah the very geographical dead center
of america that has some really peculiar effects
uh people who think they know a little
bit more than they actually know
they go who's the ip address that's annoyed me
i'll find the latitude longitude and show up there
people who live in that middle address in america
that's in the very middle of america sometimes
find random strangers showing up at their house
annoyed with them because they think some company
lives there or they think somebody's trying
to hack them from there sorry to those people
living in that home yeah it's actually is
really unfortunate for them because until
ipg location was a thing it was just some address
in america but now it's the very middle of america
can work out very unhappily for them so this is
the bit of code anyway that takes this string
i p address sends out a request gets some jason
back passes that jason and gets me a latin long
and i've got some base error checking this is not
brilliant code i hacked it together in an hour
a couple of nights ago now the other thing i
need to do is send out a traceroute command
so here's a python sending out a traceroute to
some ip address that i'm going to pass in from
the command line i'm going to use some basic
map plotting and i'm going to pass through
the individual lines of my command line output
split out the ip address on this line here
do some basic passing to see if it's one
of those stars or an error line and if
i have a new latitude and longitude and if
i've got some previous latitude and longitude
i'm going to draw a great circle line so i'm
just calling a library routine here to do it
and plot that on the map so let's have
a look at that working to somewhere
interesting so if we go to the sydney dot edu dot
ayu you'll take a little bit of time to go through
the traceroute command and we'll see it's working
there sending out those sequences of three packets
and now it's going to pop up the map of the world
and we can see more or less where it's going so
there's one big great circle hop from london i
suspect i'm not sure i suspect that that is that
is that middle of america address i told you
about that's definitely not new york is it
no no no that's not new i suspect that all it
knows about the server there is it's in america
and that's the middle we've got a hop out to the
west coast there looks like it's somewhere in
california and then bang all the way down to
australia i think we can also say look kink
there as it comes in on the coast there and then
makes its way down to sydney for the final bit
can we try somewhere random somewhere different
uct cape town today okay cape town very nice place
yeah so now we're doing our route to cape town
south africa i have no idea what this one will
actually look like okay it's going by the way i'm
always doing the web server because i i suspect
that the web server will be a single machine
on that oh well that's not as interesting as i
uh we can't see too much i don't think that's
a full great circle i think there's a there's
a sort of central hop there if we hop over
to tokyo so let's try and get us over to the
university of tokyo which is in japan and again
it's going to pop up the route we can see when
we get a big jump from 27 to 100 that's it jumping
over an ocean that's jumping over another one so
it's interesting to me that it tends to go westly
is that because of america being a powerhouse
in the internet you can also find that sometimes
different places even with their country will swap
around and i have seen this i'm not going to run
it until it does but i have seen this swap round
and and at another time of day it will take
the eastbound route blue cost of one and
nothing else because we haven't yet switched
on green so now our black is switched on blue
direction the signal is moving in so the
speed of those pulses tell us the rate
we know which direction it is because we know
which roller is coming from and we can look
[MANUAL PUBLISH]